let me see your hands
[Applause]
[Music]
okay he's still in there yes he's still
in there what kind of gun does he have
he has a nine glass miller man he has
license to carry he usually armed
security guard okay so my fear is that
he gonna hurt himself
um is the house unlocked i don't know
after i left i just got the hell out of
there because he cut the lights out
okay well we're gonna have to take him
into custody his name is
yes
okay and we're gonna need your keys to
see if it's unlocked
what's your name
okay and briefly what happened tonight
we went to his parents house had dinner
at his parents
in the house we'll get the long story
yep we gotta start arguing because i
wouldn't come to bed
when he wanted to go to bed okay so he
turned out all the lights on how did the
gun come into play the gun came to play
when i confronted him without turning
all the lights out on me i said why
would you turn the lights on i'm
watching tv i said well you need to come
to fit i said you can't make me go to
bed i'm not ready to go to bed
and so he came back downstairs sat down
with me
he asked me about the
wood that was in the backyard and i said
i'll just grab it i'll grab it so it
doesn't get wet so i brought the wood in
and said it in the room
and because i didn't hear him what he
said after
he did he wouldn't repeat himself so he
got upset and so i said i'm just sick
and tired of trying to explain myself or
you're always upset about everything i'm
not ready to go to bed okay when he did
he pulled out the gun and pointed at you
no he just had him in his hand he had it
in his hand he cocked it well i was
upstairs in the bed he cocked the gun
and he said i'm sick and tired of the
shit okay did i cause you to fear for
your safety yes all right that's why i
love you just waiting in the car for us
though yeah okay
i can unlock it with the beeper yeah
okay tell you what i'll just take this
off here because this is a hook on here
and then you can keep the rest of the
keys all right yes
pink one
victim is outside suspect is inside
we're trying to make entry
police
dock's not working
police dog in front
[Applause]
oh
oh
you